Peter Joseph Oosterhouse was a very
interesting major-general a civil war he
was one of very few German major
generals in the Civil War there were
only two others that had been immigrants
to the United States as adults I am the
great great granddaughter of Peter
Joseph foster house and I knew very
little about him when I started digging
into genealogy I looked for information
about it and I found a lot of
discrepancies in the little bit of
information that I could find and I
thought as I dug into it more and more
deeply that there's a story there
because he did a lot more than anyone
has given him credit for he he started
the war in Missouri in the very first
battle west of the Mississippi and he
ended the war signing the last surrender
document west of the Mississippi in
between he was on a fourteen hundred
mile front and he participated in almost
every major battle in the Western
theater except for Shiloh he was in
Vicksburg campaign the Chattanooga
campaign and the Atlanta Campaign the
Germans fought mostly for the north in
the Civil War because that's where they
mostly landed when they immigrated
that's where the jobs were a lot of them
were farmers but they were also skilled
or unskilled workers and there was not
that much for them to do in the south so
demographically there were way more
Germans in the north and ever were in
the south Peter Joseph who was as a
rebel in the German Revolution of 1848
and
and as his other fellow forty-eighters
who were also rebels in that war found
when they came to the United States the
the idea of the United States
disintegrating was horrible to them
because they had been fighting for unity
for a united country in Germany and now
they were seeing what they thought was a
fine united country here trying to break
up again and that just horrified them
he's been sort of forgotten I call him
the unknown general because there are
several reasons first of all the Western
campaign itself was not well covered by
the press at that time second of all he
was an ethnic and everybody just assumed
that he was commanding other ethnics and
there was limited interest in those
except as how they failed in their in
their missions I think they think that
this book uh peels to not only people
who were curious about the Western
campaign in the Western theater because
that area of scholarship has been
neglected until the last few years but
also he turns out to have been the best
German born field general of any of them
and has gotten very little attention so
I'm thinking that any German American
might be very interested in finding out
what his contribution as representative
of the two hundred and two hundred
thousand other Germans who fought in the
Civil War for the north represented it
was a much bigger contribution than he's
been given credit for